donald trump da marcha atrás después de
bloquear durante varios días el proyecto
de ley de estímulos por 900.000 millones
de dólares acordado por republicanos y
demócratas en el congreso el presidente
saliente firmó sorpresivamente la
iniciativa el domingo en la noche como
presidente de eeuu en mi responsabilidad
de proteger a la gente en nuestro país
de la devastación y las dificultades
causadas por el virus chino sin embargo
por la inacción de camps cerca de 14
millones de estadounidenses perdieron
las ayudas por desempleo ya que
expiraron el domingo para no firmar su
amistad en que los 600 dólares de ayudas
para los ciudadanos afectados por la
pandemia no eran suficientes
un argumento sorpresivo ya que los
mismos republicanos eran los que se
oponían a que se aumentara la ayuda de
berna créanlo o no los demócratas están
de acuerdo con el presidente de 600
dólares no son suficientes para los
individuos que la han pasado mal durante
los últimos 7 meses y no son suficientes
para darle un impulso a las necesidades
de nuestra economía el mandatario
aseguró que a pesar de que se firmó el
proyecto de ley todavía espera que el
congreso apruebe un cambio en el
subsidio al aumentar lo de 600 a 2.000
dólares
el proyecto de ley incluye miles de
millones de dólares para ayudar a los
estados con la distribución de vacunas
un programa de préstamos para pequeñas
empresas además de un presupuesto para
mantener al gobierno financiado durante
el resto del año fiscal